as you may have heard President Biden
told our own peter Ducey this week that
he wasn't making a stop at the border
during his visit to Arizona because
there were quote more important things
going on but while the Border may not be
a personal priority for this President
his administration is now seeking more
funding and asking Congress for three
billion dollars to help deal with their
self-inflicted border crisis a crisis
that is expected to only get worse once
the title 42 border protections are
formally lifted here now with reaction
our Fox News contributor Sarah Carter
who's been on this issue from the start
and the president of the national border
patrol Council Brandon Judd Brandon let
me start with you we saw that footage
remarkable work by law enforcement on
the ground there with Texas and yet of
course we still know that we're as Bill
noted we're understaffed the resources
you guys need you don't have and now you
got people coming in with bags full of
ammunition how do you see this still
folding uh really unfolding when it
comes to the American people learning
about all of this what are you trying to
get at this point from the
administration to slow this down well
I'm absolutely disgusted that Texas DPS
has to do my job I'm disgusted that we
don't have enough agents um in that area
to actually interdict these people
before Texas DPS has to get into vehicle
chases like this
um if we had the resources that were
necessary if we had the proper policies
and programs that were necessary we
could do the job in securing the the
border and we could protect the American
people and that's what we have to have
and what's interesting about that is is
it does not cost the American taxpayer a
dime to have proper policies and
programs in place he completely and just
and and he completely gutted everything
that we were able to accomplish under
President Trump simply because he wants
to appease his far left base and that
does not serve the American people and
again that is monstrous to see what he
has currently done um to the Border
situation not giving us the proper
policies and programs that are necessary
you know it's interesting because they
want three billion dollars that's a lot
of money and they aren't really saying
what they're going to do with it and the
Republicans don't want to give it
understandable before the border is
closed which it seems like that's never
going to happen do you think that money
is is going to would go to more border
patrol agents and would go to security
what's going on absolutely not no all
that money is going to do is going to
facilitate more people to get release
into the United States quick quicker
when you look at the total numbers we
have already released close to 4 million
people into the United States and then
on top of that we've had more than a
million gotaways um into the United
States all he's trying to do is process
and facilitate the release of people
even quicker so Sarah I hear you
agreeing over there I mean this CL it's
obvious this is about I don't know maybe
it's buying more hotel rooms I don't
know what they want to do with the 3
billion but it's not about securing this
country
no it isn't it isn't Tammy and this is
about a nightmare scenario that is going
to get far worse I mean his own DHS
officials are guesstimating that there
will be 18
000 people per day trying to enter the
United States right now we're looking at
seven thousand to ten thousand and
Brandon's right I mean when you look at
the known godaways these are people that
have not even been vetted this is a
national security crisis it's a
humanitarian crisis Tammy I mean what we
saw Bill malusian report on is the same
things that I've been seeing and he's
been seeing for the last several years
now that's going to be double quadruple
triple we have a hundred and thirty
thousand just in 2022 unaccompanied
minors entering the United States a lot
of these children are abused they're
some of them are actually sold into the
sex Market into slavery we've seen women
raped we have seen the cartels amass
hundreds of billions of dollars they've
been able to buy semi submersible people
submarines right equipment uh weapons
this is so out of control and the only
thing
that the Biden policy is doing is
creating more chaos and allowing this to
happen so yes they have tied the hands
of our border patrol agents we've seen
that over and over again they have tied
the hands of our law enforcement our FBI
our DEA and now what we're going to
witness As Americans is something that
we've never expected and we've already
lost a hundred thousand a hundred
thousand people to Fentanyl and opioid
overdose just last year right so imagine
how we're gonna have we're gonna have
Brandon we're going to have title 42
possibly lifted on December 21st uh the
Biden Administration says they're suing
to stop that but but a DHS official
actually equated it to it being a good
time to do it because it's not so close
to the election that's coming up I mean
can you can you the mentality here this
is going to become as you've both
discussed even worse and there seems to
be no effort at all to to mitigate this
in any fashion
pure politics and when you look at when
you look currently Tammy we are at times
we have 90 percent of our resources that
are doing administrative duties
um we don't even have 50 of our
resources to begin a shift that is on
the border patrol on the border and then
by the end of the shift we have taken um
of 60 70 80
um percent of our resources out of the
field to do administrative duties to to
do Hospital watch transport
um processing this is not what border
security was supposed to be and that's
why we're seeing I have to tell you
chaos yeah I have to tell you Sarah and
this is with I think the title 42 that
when that gets lifted it's noted that
the extra money is going to be needed in
part to process shelter and transport
all of the people who are now able to
get into the country once that title 42
is lifted so they anticipate that it
will be and now even though we're
fighting it but now they want the money
to make sure that we've got uh uh the
highway into the United States it's all
set up and comfortable for them
yeah we'll be the last leg of literally
trafficking human beings into the
country so why should why should the
human traffickers why should uh the drug
cartels stop what they're doing because
we're aiding and abetting in their
nefarious actions Tammy and not only
that who's going to tell the children
that are being sold into sex trafficking
the children that are lost the children
that have died that the United States of
America that's supposed to stand on
principle is actually aiding and
abetting the cartels the worst people on
planet Earth in in their
incentivizing demise we we have
incentivized from the start this entire
Dynamic with children being moved in and
then us facilitating their movement into
with to strangers throughout this
country it is when we look back on this
and we will we're it's going to be
horrific and shocking many nations in
the world have to look back on their
histories and have to reconcile what it
is they did it and sometimes they never
do this is that time and of course uh
hopefully we'll uh be keeping the
Republicans and making it be not too
horrific in the future both of you thank
you very much for for joining us tonight
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else